today is also the last day that we are
raising money d campaign at david
pakman.com slash donate and tonight at
midnight and it's a horrible day in
america Donald Trump is being
inaugurated as the orange president of
the United States it's a very very sad
day and many people are email emailing
me about it gloating the trumpets they
really are gloating my question to them
in two years will be and we're going to
track this show me statistics that tell
me you are better off today than you
were two years ago or in four years the
same question will apply now the very
very very rich the few hundred people
that will really benefit big-time from
the repeal of Obamacare for example
they'd probably be able to show that in
statistics but the average person is not
going to be able to show that they're
better off we need to hold Trump
accountable this is such a key moment
for independent progressive media and
that's why I'm asking you for the last
time today please look at the campaign
we're running at david pakman.com slash
donate if it seems worthwhile to you and
it's very worthwhile and important to me
please make the contribution that you
can make and if it's just a few dollars
that's fine and if it's a hundred bucks
that's great and if it's five thousand
dollars that's fantastic as well because
we are going to be here in a more
desperate and crucial role than i can
recall in the history of the david
pakman show with you thanks to everybody
who's already contributed five hundred
or even more donors so far if there are
some major final contributions out there
if there are some minor or moderate
final contributions out there gediman
were here with you today we will have
coverage of the inauguration on monday
david pakman.com slash donate we'll take
a break it is the last show of the obama
administration the first show of the
trump administration